DrDr PATRICK BELLEMARE,
pnpneumologue, Hôpital Sacré-Cor
- - Là, il y a quelqu'un qui, pr
vrvrai, a été à jeûn depuis mint
hihier soir, qui s'attendait à e
fafaire faire sa chirurgie à cor
ououvert aujourd'hui, puis qui
n'n'aura pas sa chirurgie à coer
ououvert.
- - Parce que?
- - Parce que la ressource est
ococcupée puis la ressource est
ococcupé en partie par la COVID.
YVYVES CAMPAGNA, en attente
d'd'une chirurgie à coeur ouvert
- - J'avais un rendez-vous
cece matin pour une opération
mamajeure. Je devais me rendre
icici pour six heures. Je me sus
rerendu ici pour six heures.
J'J'ai attendu jusqu'à une heur,
jujusqu'à temps qu'on m'avise qe
çaça avait été cancellé. Parce
ququ'on n'était pas en mesure de
meme donner une opération, alors
onon va la remettre à plus tard.
OnOn n'en parle depuis plusieurs
jojours, bonsoir à tous les tro.
JeJe reçois beaucoup de courrie.
OnOn me dit qu'il y a presque ps
d'd'hospititalisation. Pourquoie
gogouvernement s'énerve? D'abor,
elelles augmentent. Il y a des
coconséquences réelles. Le Doctr
BeBellemare à l'honnêteté de le
didire, ce n'est pas que la COV,
lele système de la santé est
ététiré. Mais c'est aussi la
COCOVID. À Sacré-Coeur, ils y a
trtrois malades sont arrivés en
sosoins intensifs COVID SA a
rereporté l'opération. C'était s
prprévu. On fait un tour de tabe
llà-dessus. Josée Legault, c'est
susur le plancher des vaches, sr
lele terrain dans les hôpitaux.
- - C'est dans la vraie vie. Ce
n'n'est pas une question de
nonombre. C'est une question dea
foforte possibilité que ça
auaugmente. Tous les experts et
mmême le ministre de la santé
l'l'on dit : il faut s'attendreà
unune hausse des hospitalisatios
àà cause de la très haute
cocontagiosité du variant Delta.
EtEt ce, malgré la vaccination.
AuAujourd'hui, Mélanie Drouin,
didirectrice de la santé publiqe
àà Montréal, elle a aussi averti
ququ'on voyait même des personns
dodouble vacciner finir à
l'l'hôpital. Donc, ça va être ue
miminorité, mais ça va quand mêe
ararriver. C'est la férocité du
vavariant Delta. Donc oui,
heheureusement, il faut montrer
cecette réalité, mais il ne faut
papas s'arrêter justement au
nonombre immédiat, il faut se
prprojeter dans ce qui s'en viet
dede ce qui s'en vient, ce n'est
papas décemment réjouissant.
- - D'où les débats politiques i
cocommencent sur la vaccination
obobligatoire dans tel secteur,
popour des employés de l'État, s
coconséquences, on les punit, on
leles punit pas? Le passeport
vavaccinal. C'est le début de tt
çaça. Il va falloir s'habituer à
çaça.
- - Sur la vaccination
obobligatoire, on regarde
seseulement sur les deux derniès
sesemaines, c'est de plus en pls
llà où on s'en va dans de plus n
plplus d'endroit. On surveille
dadans le moment l'Ontario par
exexemple qui résiste à l'idée e
papasseport vaccinal. Selon moi,
cecette résistance ne va pas
dudurer. Et l'idée qu'il va
fafalloir être vaccinée, pas
seseulement pour aller au
rerestaurant ou autre, mais pour
ococcuper des emplois, Air Canaa
auaujourd'hui, les conséquences
vovont être réelles, ce ne sera
papas : on vous testera quelques
fofois par semaine. Cette idée,
ininévitablement, va gagner du
teterrain au cours des prochains
sesemaines.
- - Michel C Auger.
- - La pandémie n'est pas
teterminée. Quand on dit : il ny
a a pas de mort, ce n'est pas
grgrave, ce n'est pas vrai. Ça a
papas besoin d'être un très grad
nonombre pour causer des vrais
prproblèmemes dans les hôpitaux.
NoNotre système de santé avant a
papandémie était à la corde.
AlAlors, il ne faut pas non plus
ququ'on commence à utiliser trop
lele vocabulaire retour à la
nonormale, etc. On n'est pas
enencore au moment du retour à a
nonormale. Il ne faut pas penser
quque le passeport vaccinal est
unune espèce de sauf-conduit por
totous. Ce ne sera pas sa et cee
sesera pas sa tant que cette vae
nene sera pas passée. Et peut-êe
ququ'il y en aura une après. One
lele sait pas. Quand j'entends e
dodocteur aux États-Unis dire, u
prprintemps, la septième vague.
- - José rapidement.
- - On oublie qu'il y a des
huhumains dans les lits des
hhôpitaux, des Québécois et
QuQuébécoises, qui vont peut-ête
susurveiller, mais qui vont avor
dedes séquelles très longtemps.
AlAlors, ça joue sur tous les
tatableaux.
- - Retour à la normale, non, ms
lele passeport vaccinal, c'est e
fafaçon de cohabiter avec ça
nonormalement. Vous allez alleru
rerestaurant avec votre fils,
ChChantal va aller au restaurant
avavec son fils, on va pouvoir
sosortir, c'est ça aussi l'idée
ququi est proposée.
- - C'est surtout pour convaince
ceceux qui ne veulent pas se fae
vavacciner. Si vous ne pouvez ps
alaller au restaurant, aller jor
auau soccer, vous allez avoir ds
prproblèmes. Je pense que c'est
plplus ça que le retour à la
nonormale. Quand on emploie ce
vovocabulaire, on est à côté.
- - Pour la même raison, quand
JuJustin Trudeau dit : vous ne
popourrez pas prendre l'avion,
trtrain, autobus, ce n'est pas
popour compter des points en
cacampagne électorale, c'est por
momotiver des gens qui ne sont s
vavaccinés à se faire vacciner.
- - Très bien. Afghanistan, la
poporte s'est refermée. Selon le
vévétéran, sur les 400 familles,
c'c'est reconnu par le
gogouvernement aussi, il y a 400
fafamilles qu'on visait qui état
dadans des abris, dans des
mamaisons, et se cacher, il y ea
7070 qu'on a pu faire entrer à
l'l'aéroport qui sont soit part,
sosoit en sécurité à l'intérieur
dedes murs. Le reste, je vous fs
enentendre le ministre qui le
rereconnais presque clairement,
c'c'est pas mal fini.
- - Comme j'ai été très clair
dedepuis les débuts, les taliba,
c'c'est des terroristes.
NoNous n'allons pas...
nonous n'avons pas l'intention
dede les reconnaître. Nous allos
cocontinuer de travailler pour
sasauver le plus grand nombre
dede personnes possibles
dede l'Afghanistan dans
leles jours à venir, mais aussi
dadans les mois à venir.
- - Alors, l'analyse sera longu.
OnOn ne peut pas tirer de
coconclusions aujojourd'hui. Cei
esest certain, c'est que le Cana
vava laisser derrière pas mal de
momondes qui ont aidé le Canada.
CÇa fait mal à beaucoup de monde
auau Canada. Dans les médias
ananglophones, je le disais hie,
jeje leur ai souligné aujourd'h,
c'c'est une histoire qui a ouvet
avavec beaucoup plus d'ampleur
ququ'ici au Québec. CTV News oue
avavec ça tous les jours, tous s
sosoirs. Le globe and mail,
ToToronto star. Michel C Augerùu
enen êtes-vous dans l'analyse
popolitique de cette crise?
- - De choses. Le Canada n'a pas
leles ressources pour sortir ces
gegens. Il va les laisser sur
plplace. C'est tragique, mais
c'c'est comme ça. Vous savez,
ququand on regarde ce qui se
papasse, je regardais la télé
frfrançaise, il y avait une espe
dede commando de militaires
frfrançais qui allaient chercher
leles gens. Le Canada n'a pas eu
leles moyens de faire ça. Est-ce
quque c'est la faute du
gogouvernement? Je ne sais pas,e
nene suis pas un expert militai.
LeLe Canada ne l'a pas fait. C't
unune chose. L'autre chose, il
fafaut quand même se rappeler qe
lele fiasco général convoi n'est
papas le fait du Canada, mais le
fafait de l'administration
amaméricaine. Bon, là, on sent e
lele Canada va être obligé de
papartir beaucoup plus rapidemet
quque le 31 août. Le 31 août, ce
sosont les derniers Américains i
vovont fermer la place. Les auts
vovont partir avant, c'est
évévident. Il y a encore moins e
chchance qu'on puisse sortir
bebeaucoup de gens de
l'l'Afghanistan.
- - Chantal.
- - Selon le globe and mail, c't
dedemain qu'on va commencer à
sosortir de là. Le dernier avion
ququi pourrait ramener des gens
ququi ne sont pas des soldats
cacanadiens qui sont la va
prprobablement quitter Kaboul
dedemain. Et après, ça n'ira pas
plplus loin. Est-ce que les
lilibéraux se passeraient de ce
gegenre d'images en campagne
élélectorale? Est-ce qu'on peut
dodouter qu'ils ont fait tout ce
ququ'il pouvait pour essayer dee
titirer de ce pétrin en campagne
élélectorale? Je pense qu'on ne
pepeut pas en douter. Il y a des
gegens qui disent : s'il n'y avt
papas eu de campagne électoralen
auaurait fait différemment.
J'J'aurais tendance à dire : s'l
n'n'y avait pas eu de campagne
élélectorale, on aurait fait mos
bibien. Mais dans le grand
poportrait, celui qui n'est pasa
cacampagne électorale, je suis
cucurieuse de voir quel impact a
vava avoir sur la relation Canaa
dodoit américaine. J'ai
l'l'impression que l'idée de cee
grgrande et bonne relation entre
JoJoe Biden et Justin Trudeau a
vévécu au cours dedes deux derns
sesemaines, on n'a pas
l'l'impression que les Américais
onont faite grand-chose pour
tetendre la main aux Canadiens.
C'C'est pas la première fois
dedepuis l'arrivée de ce nouveau
prprésident américain. Mais pour
l'l'instant et de plus en plus,
j'j'ai l'impression que les
CaCanadiens se disent :
fifinalement, son principal
mémérite, c'est de ne pas être
DoDonald Trump.
- - C'est une tragédie sur
plplusieurs plans. C'est éviden.
JeJe pense que ça va être à chae
élélecteur de poser son jugemen.
OnOn va voir pendant les débats
cocomment le premier ministre va
sese défendre là-dessus. On peut
dédébattre de la question. On pt
sese demander si le gouvernement
TrTrudeau a vraiment fait tout e
ququ'il pouvait faire dans la
memesure où ça soulève la questn
: : préparer suffisamment? Je ne
susuis pas une experte non plus
mimilitaire. Mais je des experts
ilil y en a plusieurs qui soulèe
cecette question, pas seulement
enenvers les Canada, les États-
UnUnis, la France etc.
- - A dit que c'était une honte.
- - Exactement. Avant-coureurs
ététaient quand même. On pourrat
didire que c'est pas la première
fofois qu'un pays occidental ne
vovoit pas venir une crise. Mais
ilil faut quand même les voir
vevenir. Le 20 septembre. Tea
PaParty des débats et des
didiscussions entre les chèques.
TrTrès bien.
QuQu'avez-vous pensé du texte qe
MaMadame Monsef sur les taliban?
ERERIN O'TOOLE, chef,
PaParti conservateur du Canada
- - Le gouvernement Trudeau
a a utilisé un langage
tototalement inacceptable.
ApAprès six mois d'inaction
papar le gouvernement Trudeau,
ilil y a des milliers d'Afghans
enen danger à cause de leur
sosoutien de notre pays.
OnOn a besoin de leadership.
OnOn a besoin d'un plan.
- - Chantal, qu'est-ce que vous
avavez pensé de ça?
- - Erin O'Toole a évité de dire
lele nom de Madame M Monsef, coe
mémédecine qui a dit : je ne vas
papas critiquer la ministre, sur
leles médias sociaux, des gens
l'l'traitent de sympathisante
teterroriste. C'est une réfugiée
dede parents Afghans. On est mal
plplacé pour le faire. Ce n'état
papas un bon choix de mots. Mais
çaça me semble être une immense
didistraction de ce que José a
ququalifié de tragédie avec
raraison.
- - Qui suis-je? Michel C Auger.
- - N'importe qui qui a passé un
pepetit peu de temps dans un pas
mumusulman, appelé quelqu'un mon
frfrère, ma soeur, c'est normal,
c'c'est comme ça qu'on s'adresse
auaux gens. On faisait un
plplaidoyer aux talibans pour de
dede les laisser sortir les gen.
JeJe trouve que c'est une tempêe
dadans un verre d'eau.
- - Josée Legault, rapidement, e
veveux parler du troisième lien.
- - Ce qui me dérange beaucoup
dadans ce qui s'est passé, ce
tetexte a été écrit. Il a été
écécrit par des gens qui ne
sesemblaient pas réaliser que la
miministre ne parlaient pas en n
nonom personnel parce que les
miministres, elle parlait au nom
dudu gouvernement du Canada et u
prpremier ministre aussi Justin
TrTrudeau. Elle a dit : non
frfrères, elle n'a pas dit mes
frfrères, elle a dit non frères.
EtEt nous vous demandons de
fafaciliter l'évacuation de
l'l'Afghanistan. Ces deux nous,
c'c'est le gouvernement du Cana.
C'C'est peut-être pour ça aussi
quque Erin O'Toole n'a pas
mementionné le nom de la ministe
mamais plutôt il a fait référene
auau gouvernement. Je pense que
c'c'est grave. Ça nécessite un
rerectificatif de la part du
prpremier ministre plus importat
quque celui qu'il a fait
auaujourd'hui.
- - Très bien. Yves-François
BlBlanchet en faveur du troisièe
lilien. Je vous fais écouter ça
totout de suite et on revient.
YVYVES-FRANÇOIS BLANCHET,
chchef, Bloc québécois
- - Est-ce que j'ai envie de fae
lala job du gouvernement du Quéc
àà la place du gouvernement
dudu Québec? Clairement pas.
OnOn m'a demandé, ça semblait
dede bonne guerre : On veut
avavoir ton avis personnel.
ApAprès que je le donne, là,
ilil faudrait que la campagne
féfédérale du Bloc québécois, qi
esest un parti fédéral, devienne
unune campagne sur un enjeu
dudu gouvernement du Québec.
JeJe crois que le troisième lien
a a un potentiel de contribution
popositive en termes
d'd'environnement, notamment por
évéviter un nombre important de
vévéhicules faisant un important
dédétour, chacun émettant
dedes gaz à effet de serre,
sasauf ceux qui sont électrique,
etet ayant un potentiel d'offre
dede transport collectif
enentre deux centres-villes
écéconomiquement très intégrés.
- - José, un projet
enenvironnemental d'une certaine
fafaçon?
- - C'est sûr. Je pense qu'il ya
bebeaucoup de désaccord sur cete
ququestion. C'est là qu'on voit
quque le chef du Bloc québécois,
ilil s'est piégé lui-même d'une
cecertaine manière dès l'électin
dede 2019 où il a transformé le
BlBloc québécois, il lui a donné
unun gros succès, mais il a
trtransformé en pigeon voyageuru
gogouvernement Legault à Ottawa.
C'C'est sûr que dès qu'il y a un
didifférend dans sa propre base
enenvers une politique du
gogouvernement Legault, ça le mt
dadans une situation intenable.t
c'c'est, j'imagine, la raison pr
lalaquelle on a assisté
auaujourd'hui à l'acrobatie très
bebelle et pas très bonne, à mon
huhumble avis, Monsieur Blanchea
auaussi fait une distinction ene
lala position de son parti et sa
poposition personnelle. Ça
dedevenait incompréhensible. Mas
c'c'est ça. Juste terminé là-
dedessus, le Bloc québécois seme
avavoir de la difficulté à faire
lala distinction entre les
inintérêts du Québec, qu'il est
cecensé défendre, et les intérês
dudu gouvernement du Québec, qul
ququ'il soit, caquiste, libéral,
ququel qu'il soit, caquiste,
lilibéral, etc.
- - Michel C Auger.
- - Je suis d'accord avec José.
MoMonsieur Blanchet a toujours é
unun peu étrange comme
enenvironnementaliste. Quand il
ététait ministre de
l'l'environnement, c'est lui qua
sisigné le décret pour que la
cicimenterie, le projet le plus
imimportant pour faire des gaz à
efeffet de serre au Québec ne st
papas soumis à des audiences du
BABAPE. Il s'en vend encore
auaujourd'hui. C'est lui qui
trtrouvait que les forages à l'e
d'd'Anticosti, ce n'était pas ue
mamauvaise idée est que ça pouvt
êêtre fait de façon écologique.
AlAlors, comme grand
enenvironnementaliste, on
rerepassera. Il reste que la
réréalité, c'est que c'est un
dédébat qu'on peut faire dans ue
cacampagne électorale fédérale
paparce que le gouvernement du
QuQuébec va demander de l'argent
dudu fédéral et quand l'argent u
pupublic est impliqué, ça deviet
unune question dont on doit
débattre en campagne électorale.
- - Il a dit : c'est une questin
dede Québec. C'est tous les
QuQuébécois qui vont payer et ts
leles Canadiens parce que l'appt
dudu Canada serait de 4 milliar.
- - D'un côté, il y a le NPD dot
lala position est claire, c'est
nonon. Il y a les conservateurs,
susurtout dans la région de
QuQuébec, qui ont des sièges qui
dodoivent être dans la mise du
blbloc, qui disent : on est prêà
papayer, donnez-nous la facture,
onon va payer 40 %. C'était
mamaladroit. Monsieur Blanchet t
enen politique depuis trop
lolongtemps pour penser qu'il ya
unune distinction entre son avis
pepersonnel et la position de sn
paparti. Ce serait comme de dire
quque Justin Trudeau, premier
miministre du Canada, pourrait
avavoir des opinions personnells
ququi seraient différent de la
popolitique du gouvernement.
- - Mais il veut passer à autre
chchose. Les libéraux, rapideme,
onon vererra, Monsieur Trudeau t
: : on va vous présenter notre.
EsEst-ce que on verra plus durer
jujusqu'au 20 septembre?
- - Officiellement, la positionu
gogouvernement, c'était Monsieur
DuDuclos qu'il avait donné, on
popourrait financer la partie du
trtransport en commun, mais on a
auaucun programme à Ottawa pour
fifinancer des autoroutes. Je
pepense que ça se tient comme
poposition du gouvernement
féfédéral.
- - Si la tentation était grande
dede faire des gains au Québec,
vovous pensez que ça pourrait
bobouger d'ici la fin?
- - Du côté du gouvernement
TrTrudeau?
- - Oui.
- - J'en serais étonné.
- - Ça ne bougera pas?
- - Je serais renversé. Il y a
ququelques sièges à Québec et ts
dadans la région de Montréal oue
trtroisième lien, ce